brief a rischio future monetizzati più
il video se parli inglese così mi hanno
detto però può bastare così io dopo lan
inglese per tutto il video signori siamo
tornati su queste api la registrazione
sul telefono magari è meglio
we are back to the last piano la torre
due volte due torri the fair store e 100
piani in casi se con torre torre annex
un altro caos causin great and we have
the seasons award season tower hill
della torre per entrarci lo guardava
pubblicità mini sbatto list i giochini
stupidi mi fate giocare per cortesia
allora ci sono un sacco di piani molto
strani
ce ne sono altre sono tutte le big non
so quanti livelli la fiom sta che
scatterà il primo piano allora sembra
molto non capisco che cosa devo fare qua
allora ci sono delle zucche un piano è
halloween il tema di inserire devo
inserire una password bene l'importante
è saperlo visto che ci sono solo due
maledettissime lettere quello potrebbe
essere un problema
qualcuno mi spiega cosa dovrei fare
ma ci sono anche altre lettere che ne so
io ah ok allora ml fts di tua sorella
non c'è una maledettissima vocale quindi
spiegatemi come dovrei fare però va bene
credo che sia tipo l'alfabeto giusto
quindi dovevo partire dall'ala che si
parte da a e la tastiera dove la
tastiera la devo scrivere la parola che
ne so
halloween immagini immagino alla
tastiera mi dice che la h
madonna che casino due tasti a destra
della effe di h
no sta prendendo
demonio quella ska dei brand taccio h è
un tasto rotto guardate la vostra
tastiera così capite cosa sto facendo
non sono un pazzo si sta della s ce la
ha quindi a gesù mille anni per scrivere
halloween
ok va bene siamo arrivati al piano due
ce ne mancano mille perché noi
tranquilli c'è una ciotola gigante se
devo cucinare sono cavoli vostri fermi
tutti qua ci potrebbero provare in fondo
ci sono delle ragnatele
se ci sono delle ragnatele io non vado
d'accordo con queste cose va bene ma io
non so cosa fare scotto sempre il
telefono perché non a volte cadono robe
prove se non me c'è qualcosa di nascosto
che non vedo da parte lo scopo di harry
potter a martello come martello per ha
spaccato il caso prendo il coso lo
mettono il rubinetto rubinetto riempio
la vasca con la vasca ci faccio il bagno
e ci affogo tua sorella
c'è una mela non potevi prendere lamela
dalla dalla ciotola 6 pigro hai dovuto
riempire spaccare un vetro mettere un
tubo riempire una vasca e prendere da me
non potrei prenderla direttamente no
andiamo avanti ragazzi l'importante è
andare avanti l'importante da ricorda
questi deficienti
c'è un'altra zucca a che si muove in
base a come nuovo io temo che è quasi un
coltello ed ha trick or treat dolcetto
scherzetto ci ho messo un attimo a
elaborare cosa volesse dire devo
tagliare la corda prendere
ok si è spiegato da solo next level
signori siamo al 3
non male non male dobbiamo finire tutto
halloween oggi anche se non ne ha dovevo
farlo ad halloween questo video però chi
se ne frega ma devo disegnare la strada
vabbè questo easy a devo fare il giro li
mortacci questa scritta maledetta mi
frega se sto gioco ti ti fa credere che
la soluzione sia una ma non è quello mai
2 3 4 5 6 set
sbagliato ecco quando su come si fanno
le cose non le so mago quindi non le so
fare neanche così quindi va giù che la
dietro alcune sono più grosse altre
hanno meno spicchi tipo
al secondo me devo toccare quelle che
hanno meno spicchi andando in quelle che
hanno un anno più spicchi questa
cavolata secondo me perché allora c'è
una freccia che indica persone stabili
devo fare qualcosa verso destra per
forza perché sono che idiota al martello
anche questa è quella che ama di più è
contrario levy let your next l'eroe vi
sono qua le mie competenze bretoni
andiamo avanti ragazzi ci sono sempre
zucche qua c'è una ci sono dei questone
tetris credo cosa vuol fare qua portello
bosco a spaccare qualsiasi cosa prova
non si muove niente qua qua che poi tra
un oggettivo da dove è uscito questo ma
questa roba scusa mi avevano sto capendo
giuro a ok a devo farlo strada era
calata una cagata incredibile davvero è
spuntato con l'oggetto letto non me ne
frega niente dei draghi dovete morire
tutti tutte number 67 72 per 7 b 8
uguale 20 ei cazzate non sanno scrivere
le i numeri questi comunque si
matematica significa horror quindi ci
hanno azzeccato il prossimo halloween
per far paura mi vesto dalla radice
quadrata un capitolo in cos'era è la
classica roba lo so già che quello c'è
fisso dove devi sommare invece dei sì
infatti 0 più 4 farebbe 4 maschi che fa
8 perché loro contano le lettere in cui
sono composti i numeri quindi 0 più four
8 scrive per sette più 8 sarebbe due
allora devo armarmi di sacro santissima
pazienza 32 più 4 fa 36 36 peuterey fa
39 30 i draghi i draghi i draghi i
draghi madonna un'ora per falso garko 39
niente poi non è tutto sto portello e
non è giusto ci riguarda se non è giusto
giuro che
[Musica]
tutto qui tutto qui qui qui preso 60 al
diploma
aqua deve illuminare i numeri nel modo
giusto bene c'è una bocca gigante ci
sono un sacco di crepe h meno y h y
perfetto ah no
h meno meno il meno meno con lo metto
tolgo i numeri che non ci sono stupido
allora i numeri che non c'entrano niente
sono quindi devo togliere quelli che ci
sono anche nella y fatti era molto molto
intuitivo solo che io abbado ogni volta
che la soluzione realtà è sempre una
cavolata se ci pensate solo che uno va a
farsi dei pensieri tipo sherlock prove
stato fatto di 222 e sapete
eccolo a caso fa caldissimo
cosa c'è ok va via non capisco a random
vedo schiacciare dei tasti non lo so non
ho capito ma è normale che sto gioco
stia diventando sempre più strano a
posto staccato la madonna che faccio qua
secondo me potremmo stare quando quante
probabilità cede azzeccare se li metti a
caso proprio randò mitch top
no non ci credo fermi fermi fermi
giuro su dio non ho visto niente non ho
visto nulla da nessuna parte da nessuna
parte ho visto niente non ci crede io
canto giocassi giochi ve lo giuro quando
gioca sta roba non so come mi vengono
però non ho visto nulla da nessuna parte
non sa darsi internet cerca mai mai
fatta non so come sia possibile le
frecce sono solo a w e sulla n
quindi quindi te lo faceva così
questo era questo questo era abbastanza
semplice l'unica cosa difficile
ammettere alla lanterna all'inizio però
questa easy questo è bellissimo c'è più
o meno ok questo me lo dovete spiegare
perché qua non so che cosa devo fare
esattamente c'è uno spaventapasseri che
in realtà spaventa qualsiasi cosa perché
il grosso
io c'ho avevi che devo tagliare la zucca
o ci ha messo un'ora a tagliare c'è chi
pare all'occhio l'occhio del coso che
[Musica]
questo questo era horror non quel non il
gioco questa non horror allora quadrupla
a tutto l'alfabeto addirittura veramente
so io qual è la password amici miei non
sta funzionando
che strano io sono sempre la risposta a
tutto in teoria dovrebbe funzionare però
vabbè non fa niente tom no come si c'è
zucca inglese minchia zucca in inglese
panchine 8 mila lettere a pipistrello
pipistrello batman bat sto dicendo
batman star o un gatto kaki cup cerci
let's go l'ex dovevi sloveni easy ed
cosa ma proviamo a spararla visto che
noi siamo bravi a pasta cagata anche
sparandole a caso quante probabilità di
azzeccare certo devono essere tutte
diverse e quasi sicuramente
signori spero che vi sia piaciuto io
sono orgoglioso di me stesso perché ogni
tanto mi sorprendo mi sorprendo grazie
mamma che mi hai fatto intelligente
ragazzi se proprio vi è piaciuto come mi
piace anche ai social condito da una
descrizione si ma se dovessi fischiate
non ci vediamo a bari
[Musica]